il a eu lieu le colonel a fait vraiment
une intervention sur un point qui qui à
chaque fois posent difficulté entre le
conjoint violent est le conjoint
victimes
pourquoi faut-il systématiquement
déplacer le conjoint victimes au lieu de
déplacer le conjoint violent
donc ça
phares on a tous été confrontés dans nos
responsabilités à ce type de situation
et un moment donné c'est insupportable
c'est la double peine voir la triple
peine jeudi
quand en plus il faut qu'on déplace les
enfants donc falloir à un moment donné
on se pose la question sur qui est
victime et qui est violent et
comment les services de sécurité de
gendarmerie et de police doivent
intervenir dans ces cas là moi j'ai
évidemment apprécié parce que je me suis
reconnu dans ses propos pour avoir été
maire d'une commune rurale
l'intervention de la représentante de la
mf cécile gallien
alors là c'est pareil je reprend deux
points qu'on a déjà évoqué que j'ai déjà
évoqué en proposition est donc peut-être
qu'elles aboutiront d'abord en finir
avec le panachage pour les communes de
moins de 1000 habitants
si on avait des scrutins de liste on
aurait des scrutins effectivement à
parité c'est quand même malheureux de
devoir gérer sa part des obligations
légales mais le panachage est aussi
malheureusement un moyen d'éliminer est
donc plutôt que de choisir quand on
propose une
une liste est donc là encore dans les
propositions en finir avec le panachage
et qu' on puisse étendre la même règle
pour les élections municipales
autre proposition qui rejoint un des
points que vous avez évoqué la création
d'un correspondant violence au même
titre qu'il y a des correspondants
défense dans les toutes les équipes
municipales
ça permet d'avoir une porte d'entrée une
tête de pont voilà et évidemment la
dernière minute je saluerai mon confrère
al adha but parce que je veux pas dire
que les pharmaciens font leur boulot on
le sait depuis des années de quick ce
métier existe donc rien d'extraordinaire
mais voilà un peu plus de choses
trois choses la première mais tu as dit
qu'on n'avait pas forcément les chiffres
j'aurais aimé savoir l'évaluation de
masques 19
je crois que comme le 39 19 qu'on a tous
lu en évidence masque 19
elle n'a peut-être pas été mis assez en
évidence mais ça aurait été bien qu'on
en est l'évaluation
deuxièmement il existe un délit de
médecine légale qui est ouvert à diplôme
d'université pendant de médecine légale
à l'université de versailles saint
quentin qui est ouvert aux pharmaciens
j'ai eu l'occasion de le faire donc ça
permet là encore d'avoir des monnaies
paramètres sadji ça permet d'avoir un
complément de formation
et puis pour que les pharmaciens sont
toujours utiles dans tous les domaines
d'activités notamment celui ci fera
qu'on préserve bien le maillage rurales
là aussi
n'ayons pas jours à lutter contre les
déserts pharmaceutique
on voit bien comment les encore les
têtes de pont peuvent être utiles
j'avais 10 5 minutes présidente s'est
fait un grand merci